the first boy bands because the formula
wasn't already there they had these
massive pop hits that were
internationally popular that is
something that minuto taught us boy
bands could do we were very
that was one of the things that we
wanted to protect them from because we
didn't want to make this a salacious
thing
you know
that they've had a lot of that
and they've only focused on salacious
salacious scandal scandal scandals and
we were like
man let's let them speak about what they
want to speak of the situation you know
people have already known about those
facts and we wanted to because the same
way like we want to celebrate menudo
it was serving all of manuel and yes the
scandals happened
but for me
there's so much they
they are so much more than that scandal
um spoil yeah i don't want to spoil it
but um yeah no spoilers but but i will
say that um you have to go see it to
really get into the nitty gritty of some
of those aspects but i think that we we
do it very tactfully you know it's not
like this gossip thing it's really
tactful and it's with the purpose of
really bringing healing and bringing
attention uh for the children of the
future really because that's the only
reason i really did this was not really
for me i debated a lot should i do it
should i not do it the reason why i did
it was because i really believe that our
experiences each one of us
serves as a historic
lesson of how to work with children how
not to work with children the things
that came out of manual but it was a
price to pay for that magic none of us
were really prepared for what it was
really going to be like there was no
interest in protecting us we felt
vulnerable it felt like i was in this
amazing band and we're traveling all
over the world but it also kind of felt
like a prison like i couldn't really be
myself or or share my experience or i
had to watch every everything that i was
doing and um so it was crazy to be so
open and so exposed but yet so stifled
and and and kind of um
imprisoned a little it was as simple as
just listening to them and listening to
where they wanted to go and what stories
they wanted to put forward so it's like
if they didn't want to go into the more
difficult parts of the story we wouldn't
have gone there
but it's
we followed their lead and
you know i think what we ended up with
is a narrative that's just more complete
you